you made it weird with Pete Holmes
what's happening weirdos this is uh the
return of Nate Craig Nate Craig is a
hilarious and wonderful man and I enjoy
chatting with him every time I get the
chance I'm so glad to share this
conversation with you he has a special
live at the Green Mill it's available
free on YouTube right now so check that
out I enjoyed every moment of it live at
the Green Mill and if you'd like to see
me me enough about Nate no we'll get to
the conversation with Nate real quick I
do want to plug September 2nd is my next
Largo show go to largo-la.com those are
always the highlight of my month we're
gonna have some really great guests this
month as well and I'm doing all this new
material also you can see me Denver sold
out thank you to everybody that got
tickets to Denver they tell me that St
Louis is sort of dragging so if you know
500 people in St Louis tell them
September 7th 8th and 9th I'll be at
Helium Comedy Club in St Louis and get
tickets at petehomes.com after that as
Raw North Carolina and then Salt Lake
City Utah these are going to be great
shows hope you can be there check it out
I'm so happy with the new material and
this is kind of your last chance to see
me do some of the old material which
won't be old to you that'll be on the
special on Netflix it'll be out at the
end of October I also want to mention
that we only do ads for things that I
actually use and actually love and the
perfect Jean is the perfect example the
perfect Gene is essentially the only
pair of pants I wear because they have
so many cuts and colors and their fabric
is incredible stretchy comfortable but
it looks good enough to wear on my
Netflix special I'm wearing perfect
jeans I wear them to movie premieres
fancy Hollywood Gatherings they look
designer they feel designer they're made
with really really high-end sewing
techniques quality craftsmanship but
here's the best thing two percent
spandex 2.5 rayon for a sneaky amount of
extra your comfort that no one needs to
know about so your man Parts aren't
crushed that's right these jeans stretch
but no one needs to know I love a soft
pant I don't know why we haven't all
switched over to the perfect Gene I
literally have a seven or eight pairs of
them I have them in khaki I have them in
dark blue I have them in Black I have
them in athletic I have them in slim
they're awesome you gotta try them out
maximum durability I never have to
replace them they last for light years
well I can't say light years they last a
really really long time in my personal
experience they are the most durable
jeans I've ever owned and the most
comfortable and the best looking jeans
I've ever owned and they're so
comfortable they're like PJ pants you
could sleep in them perfect for road
trips perfect for being on stage perfect
for if you just want to do squats in the
middle of the day and best of all
they're not khakis khakis where perfect
Jean khakis which are some of my
favorite ones they're jeans colored like
khakis and they spare your knots the
perfect Jean for the Perfectly Imperfect
men 20 off when you use code where
weirdo at checkout liberate your lower
limbs with the one and only perfect Gene
whether you're working with lemons or
lentils a three-leaf Clover or a big old
honk an eggplant the perfect Gene has
you covered take a peek at
www.theperfectgene.nyc that's the
perfect j e a n dot NYC these code
weirdo for 20 off at checkout support
your body look good feel good and
support the show it means a lot alright
everybody hope to see you in St Louis
please
and hope to see you in Utah and North
Carolina after that and hope to see you
at Largo as well on September 2nd in the
meantime enjoy Nate Craig and be sure to
check out live at the Green Mill
available on YouTube now get
into it yeah you can sponsor you drink
it baby are you excited give it a good
Shake magic Minds give it give it a good
Shake cult leader I am a cult leader
but all right here we go what's this
gonna do oh my we call it the Reckoning
you didn't shake it enough there's still
jizz on the bus I shook it oh there is
jizz
it's gonna taste a little strange now
we're mixing Pizza has anybody ever done
this before no and I don't know if I
even recommend it well just know that
that's flavored because some guests have
drank that and been like whoa
spit take and I did not a true spitty
yes but I'll say this so when I did hot
ones I wanted to bail yeah and I just
was having
no I will say this is before hot ones
became like a bad combo not a bad combo
magic mind and ABC is washed married up
nabc not a bad combo
I'm so happy to see you none of these
stories need to be told no all I'm gonna
say is I wanted to bail on hot ones I
was doing too much press it was during
HBO's Crashers and I just was like ah
just get me out of it and they were like
I think you should do it and I'm just
sometimes I'm really grateful for that
voice that will push me into that
direction away from my own baliness
because I did it and it was super fun
and then that show is super super
popular and I'm kind of like I almost
walked away no that was dumb Steph Curry
just did hot ones I mean that's what I'm
saying it's massive old homes he
couldn't do hot ones now
OMSI slipped in yeah
all the homes he slipped in when the
getting was good before it was Matt
Damon getting a walk on from Al Pacino
being like who's eating wings you know
just like now it's like intense they
have like SNL style walk-on What's it
gonna take for you all to name a wing
after me
I better do it anyway I'm so happy to
see you YouTube Odd it's been face to
face what FTF years FTF FTF it's been PP
pretty pretty pandemic oh pre-pan yeah
prepan I think pre-plan maybe I've seen
you since then it's been a the since the
since the shutdown ended it's been a
real blur of like what are we what are
we doing how and how how how how hard
are we pressing
to see folks see folks get out there you
know like it's sea fog it's been a lot
more I love your voice I do I should say
this up top I ripped through your whole
special and I love it oh dude it's a
real work of art thank you dude it's
really really good and it's really fresh
it's not like Nate Craig did a special
that happened to be when the pandemic
was ending or whatever whenever it was
released it's all this stuff that was
clearly written about what we had all
just been through oh yeah I was
scrapping bits no that's
I'm saying like you didn't go like oh
the pandemic's crazy so's hot mustard
and like move into your hot mustard no
chunk yeah you did this thing that's
very timely very topical very fearless
and like you have
I thought about this it's weird that I
thought about this compliment but you
reminded me of what I love about Chicago
comedians in particular you go silly you
get verbose you use a lot of funny
language toot sweet comes to mind I do
not a spoiler Dude Sweet and you play
but there's a theme you're doing like
your special does what I'm gonna sound
like an old person but like not a lot of
people are doing anymore
which is like there's like themes and
there's reprieves it's musical it comes
back it's on a tone and your voice is
not like anyone else's voice and you're
having fun and you're calm very hard to
do on a special taping very hard to do
it's very hard to do
you love calm you gotta stay calm Nate's
up there he's excited to do the bits two
bits becomes a junk becomes a set oh my
God I finally I anyway fantastic thank
you buddy I really appreciate it but to
keep it current I did do it there is
crowd work in there for the kids what do
you mean just that's what they like well
I was just trying in my head when you
were like this that people don't do
anymore you know and there's so much
stand-up that like you know I just meant
there's less appreciation for the the
craftsmanship people are crafting
different kinds of stuff The Arc of the
50 60 minutes yeah it just reminds me of
uh you know a lot of scandalized
comedians like Bill Cosby I care about
that show yeah the The Herald approach
to like uh you know like but it's
effortless you're doing it so cool you
look really cool meaning I just
appreciate how calm you were it's not a
it's not a punched up jacked up like
you're kind of doing it real it's very
and that's very Chicago to me
but like you don't bring up this is my
favorite compliment it's what I'm going
for you don't bring up a premise without
taking it somewhere that was worth
bothering us with trying to think of
what glamping is
no I
a lot of times the thing that I don't
like about comedians is they bring up a
topic and then they don't take you
anywhere and then you're like well what
was all that mental effort literally I
feel exhausted by it that you made me
imagine you in your kitchen with an open
robe and you're getting milk and then
you're like and now I'm in Montana
getting a haircut and I'm like you
wouldn't change you
you didn't show what go back to the
kitchen
something in the kitchen you need
Meandering [__] yeah I have I have I
can do it myself yes I can call a family
I can forget my own thoughts call an old
friend I don't know all the funny friend
in high school he's got lots of stories
like that I got a whole list of people
who can make me forget where we're at
that's right and bring it nowhere and
pay it off never and and like you do an
interesting sorry for all these
compliments but dude keep going don't
you do something that I'm here for when
I say reprieve you know like it's like
paying homage to where we were yeah
meaning it's not a callback you're not
just going like that's why we call him
big dick Mcgee and like 10 minutes
earlier you did this forced bit about
big dick Mcgee just to pay it back
you're not doing that the the set is
listening to itself so of course
organically like that would come back
and this would come back and this would
come back well clearly I made the
special for you P I really appreciate it
well how long has it been out uh we just
it dropped uh what June 1st or right
after Memorial Day so right about there
and it's I mean but we shot it we shot
it last year you're still watching Nick
special after Memorial Day dude
big big time Big Time big time don't
mention that to anybody don't tell
people you're watching it's a great
special it's a great special
mates up there he's defending the whites
he's defending us
we love Nate and we love the weights we
love Nathan we love it take on the wipes
we love talking about the whites they
deserve to be talked about I did enjoy
that you mentioned the whites but you it
is and let's stop talking about it but
like it is fearless and you do have
takes and there's moments and I can see
why Bill Burr produced it there's like a
quality to it that's unafraid and fun
that reminds me of Neil Brennan it's
like I'm gonna bring up a thing and I'm
gonna say something not not to just be
crazy yeah well I mean that's I think
you know and thank you and uh not to
agree with you 100 about my own work
yeah go ahead but like we mentioned Neil
and like and like that is such a great
special and there are yeah blocks is one
of those ones
oh my god did you watch um Dion Cole's
new latest special no we talked about
his mom passing away and stuff and it's
like after like a full hour of like
incredible jokes and it's like yeah
nowadays like I I don't it's it's either
or you're either doing like you know
absolutely instantly you know destroy
this message after watching kind of
[__] crowd work right or you're
watching somebody who's like been doing
it long enough to be like well I gotta I
this thought's got to go somewhere yeah
or I'm or I'm no longer do you know 46.
see I think that's it yeah I think
that's it I think Dion's in his 40s yeah
Neil's in his 40s yeah not to not to say
everybody gets better in their 40s but I
think and not everybody who's good is in
their 40s but I'm saying for me what you
just said now I do stand up and I'm
building to something that I really want
to say and you really know yourself and
you have something that you want to
communicate there's an urgency to it and
I felt that here I love it that means
everything thank you Pete yeah dude I as
as uh I've uh
I've been having more fun period
you know we've known each other since
damn near the beginning isn't that wild
um and it feels like a lot of times some
of those memories feel like yesterday
but you know for me I it was stand Up's
hard and I'm a little slow so like it's
been a lot more fun recently like you
know stand up is hard it's very hard
dude it's not easy at all and but also
immense one of the great things about it
is the not stopping of it is also I I'm
gonna say there's like a passive income
to stand up meaning like just you
accumulating yeah yeah to keep watching
it right it's keep your head down a
little bit it's a bit exponential and
you'll get better right it just grows on
itself without effort yeah in through
time and uh and whatever for sure a lot
of effort but but yeah I mean
there's so many distractions doing
stand-up comedy what do you mean well
just the physical distraction of like
actually getting up in a room and having
to listen to every corner of the room
every audience member you're kind of
doing it subconsciously while you're
also you know peeling through this idea
that's unfinished yeah I don't know
about you but I I tend to like kind of
loosely write bits so that I can kind of
get out of my own I've always said my
brain is way smarter than I am so if I
could just kind of get into the thought
and then have my brain kind of dig its
way out with the least amount of
syllables it'll do that on its own yeah
and like that's pays off sometimes yeah
oftentimes it does not pay off and so
then you're in the middle of that
scenario where you're like trying to
communicate to all you know all these
different elements uh but going back to
what you just said yeah because I'm with
you
it is there's a it's difficult to listen
to so many people and I'm not surprised
if to hear that you feel that way I feel
that way it's like locking on and
merging with an audience is is more
taxing than it seems and that's why I
can be so
detrimental and painful when it goes
poorly it's because you were like I was
locking it's like two ships trying to
refuel in outer space and it's like and
then they break it and he wanted them to
explode that's what it feels like to
bomb yeah but when you connect but it
takes a lot of energy in the same way
that like parties and dinner parties can
be uncomfortable for me is because I
there's just a lot of attention being
paid because you can't get overwhelmed
because I care because you care you want
to listen do you want to you want to you
want people to know that that they're
they're Landing because it because
because they do it is and it makes the
conversation more substantive when that
happens and that's just a more
interesting encounter as a human being
and it's an underrated skill for a comic
somebody who can listen to the room
I think a lot of us I'm gonna say maybe
this is shitty I think a lot of us just
aren't doing it I don't think let me put
it this way let me put it more gently
and more honestly too I just think
there's a there's a you know a spectrum
of how sensitive comedians are and I
tend to like the more sensitive ones the
ones that are like really hearing the
laugh change color just a little better
they pull away just a little bit it's
really hard for them it's they're
they're an exposed nerve Marin comes to
mind I would even say Burr is that way
like these guys that seem like Jack
hammers yeah I see little sweeties I see
little like guys that really I was just
trying to do a bit about this where I
was like anger is sadness in Disguise oh
for sure so angry anger is the colorful
candy shell on the Eminem of sadness I
was like and isn't it funny that Eminem
is the best example of this he's so sad
that his dad left he's so sad that his
mom was an addict but what sometimes
balls [__] grab my balls y'all can eat
my ass and how and I'm not trying to be
funny but like how sad in all of us when
we're up there ranting there's a sadness
there and I and those tend to be the
guys that I like and the women that I
like those tend to be the comics that
are really tuned in to the crowd with
the same intensity that they tuned in to
their alcoholic parents dinner table
yeah you know what I mean they're
they're survival they're tied to it yeah
there's betrayal there there's
disappointment there and what they want
more than anything is for somebody in
the in the room to understand them
that's exactly right yeah but you only
get it I just came back from visiting my
folks and my friend who's uh you can
take this however you want I guess what
I'm saying is I'm afraid you'll judge me
but she's intuitive she's a psychic
person and she's like I could tell you
had just seen your parents and that
every play everything you heard you were
playing at 10 miles 10 minutes down the
line just to see how it could hurt you
and get ahead of it and I was like I've
never felt more seen in my life because
that's what I'm doing with my folks I'm
like what is that okay
I'm gonna juggle these balls for Dad not
my dad's balls but I'm gonna juggle
these balls for Dad sure and how are we
all juggling our dad's balls you know I
love your bit about your the balls that
was fantastic oh my grant yeah that's uh
what is it every man is driving a Honda
or most men are balls are a Ferrari and
most men are just a Honda Accord and we
are burning through tires our whole life
yeah yeah can I tell you just to see
what you think of this like to put a
quarter in your jukebox I go I've done a
lot of drug that lists all the drugs
I've done I've never done on stage and
then go you know the craziest drug I've
done is testosterone it's [__] nuts
yeah it's nuts nuts yeah burning with
rage I'm not even trying to be funny
look to our porn look to the porn I know
there are women that might enjoy that
porn but the porn that Val is told me
that she was soft focus they're like
showering in milk and glitter and drying
each other
yeah there's a lot of kissing there's no
look at the horror that that is to me
testosterone left unchecked testosterone
doesn't have a wardrobe Department
no no it does not start filming the
moment the actors arrive and there's a
lot of improv it's [__] terrible yeah
it's horrible we are shit-faced on our
own balls that's what you said and I
love that line I thought I thought that
was fantastic thank you okay what were
you saying you're saying something else
sadness being anger is sadness in
Disguise listening Comics how tiring it
can be other things that get in the way
of stand-up that's what we were talking
about yeah just distractions well just
to make the observation just to uh I've
said listening to the crowd is an
underrated skill and it is and the
comics I love
um from you know a lot of different
reasons but but when I see somebody who
listens really well and that the best
I've ever seen is Rory Scoville I I'm
always every time I watch him I'm like
he makes mention and this can be an out
for some Comics to like be like you know
uh what you know what why do you get so
quiet in the room or thing anybody
laughs at how quiet it got you know but
but when I Swatch Roy I don't see that
at all I see him like actually me too
knowing why a joke landed the way it
landed in the room in the back
differently back there than it did over
here yeah and like that's just so
detailed where he goes it sounds like
there's a lot of church goers here and
it was just like because he was making
fun of church and he goes it sounds like
there's a lot of church goers here and I
was like that's
not to flatter myself but I think Rory
and I are like comedy Brothers you know
what I mean I I said it's a good brother
to have it is he well he's my favorite
comic which which is really saying
something is that meaning I must love
myself I do yeah when I watch my own
comedy I'm like this is what I've been
looking for and that and that's how I
hope everybody feels about their own
comedy yeah but when I watch Rory I'm
like [__]
could have done that you know who my
company brother is who Bill Burr belly B
is it true no oh that's hilarious I'm
thinking like one of the grades
I'm trying to [__] That's My
Doppelganger yeah but you know who My
Doppelganger is I'm trying to think of
something better it's a shame that I
mean everything about what happened with
Louisa shame and one one of the small
lowercase shames is how [__] great is
how funny he is yeah yeah it's like what
I'm saying is I was just about to be
like my my twin is Louise
Scandal noted however we feel about that
I'm like as a stand-up I'm like jeez I'm
Crow yeah talk about someone that brings
something up and doesn't stop until it's
[__] drained dry yeah his joke about
how Christianity won because we count
the years one year since his death two
years since his death man it's one of
the greatest well he's still working no
I know well that's that's um you can
stop Joe Mandy's but no one's been
canceled nobody's been canceled because
no one's been canceled yeah and I was
like that's a great premise it's it's
kind of tricky obviously but
yeah well it isn't feeling [__] isn't
[__]
Huxtable about to go back on tour not
Theo you mean Cliff Cliff Clifford he's
Malcolm Jamal Warner he's Clifford
I don't think that's gonna work I just
mean physically yeah I mean
are they gonna lower him on one of those
helicopter rescue orange raps he does
Five and then they just airlift him to
the hospital he's dead he's like he's a
desert person he looks like he drank
from the wrong goblet in the in the Last
Crusade he looks like Dianne Feinstein I
don't know what that is but he just the
senator from
senator from oh she from San Francisco
of course Dianne Feinstein of course I
know the senator
who sits in the Senate every state who
gets too
um yeah and and Diane is one one of them
for California California it's one of
our Senators yes are you kidding me of
course I know you know Schwarzenegger
and Diane Feinstein and Rachel finds out
and Diane find somebody yes Adam
schiffen wait is he's a representative
who's oh thanks I hear that I just hear
that in my car radio
of course I knew the other side staying
on top of it yeah Alex Padilla Funky
Cold Padilla they call they call him
because you slip it
they play
he called Medina kind of about Mickey's
like slipping people yeah that's uh
that's a clear rape yeah that's a rape
Jam
it's not just Baby It's Cold Outside
welcome back to just rape jams that was
for the 50th time today Baby It's Cold
Outside and now just to mix it up every
50th time we do Play Funky Cold Medina
who is doing it in the house remix Funky
Cold Outside Medina you could play 50
versions of Baby It's Cold Outside oh
and then mix it up with there's only
nobody remixed
sure they did he thinks that's out there
do you think so oh yeah okay I was gonna
I just watched the movie coming up from
DJ rape Funky Cold Medina he just names
himself that wow how appropriate because
no one likes it nobody likes it he uh in
the movie remember when you call me rape
you had a lot of fun with that nickname
that was something what I just called
you that yeah you just called me rape
correct well that you didn't call me I
don't think I made that burns made it up
yeah because I dry humped him in Vegas
and then that was one that it was a it
was a preemie too nickname that that uh
I was happy to lose yeah
yeah well things have changed I was I
didn't know you got married which makes
me feel like a real piece of [__] that's
okay I found out from your comedy
special yes and if there's any
indication that we're just two pirates
that just docked briefly together here
at this board docking that's what we've
that's right we've talked our wieners
together but you got married when did
you get married right before the
pandemic is it the girl because the
first time you did you made it weird
yeah the whole thing was about my
ex-girlfriend yeah I know
um no a new girl we
all have to move on
so true had gotten away moved on not her
ship it ship it ship it with someone
else if it was somebody so that girl has
been shipped with someone else yes uh
still great friends oh but uh was she at
the wedding no no no no no no no
um but not great friends then great
friends great friend but like the kind
of thing you gotta Severance don't great
friends come to the wedding you're great
friends you know the great we lost a lot
of blood you know like we we had to uh
we you know we got uh we're in different
markets no I understand
um different leagues different leagues
she's American yeah I know that yeah
we're it's the NFC AFC situation we've
gone UFC AMC but um no I mean I
met I've never been happier dude yeah
never been happier you seemed balanced
yeah I feel ph balanced I feel um where
did you meet we met this is an app you
can just turn your house
okay old school in the wild yoga class
real creep status oh I mean
it's you don't meet someone at yoga
happy ending you do you do that's the
joke in my ACT I met my wife at yoga
after yo outside uh I followed her out
of yoga that's the gag and then which
it's exactly true but then she had a
boyfriend at the time and I was like
none of that and then I invited her and
her ex to uh my fourth of July party and
she showed up if you're famous Fourth of
July party my fourth drop you've been
there you both have been there uh so
that was and then she was like she
showed up with her boyfriend she came
she did not have a boyfriend anymore and
she came with her friends do you think
she broke up with him unconsciously but
so she could be free for old natey Craig
I like to think so is this real I bet
yes I think that's actually the case I
think they were just at the end but then
they did have a trip planned to um he's
a chef and he's still looking they were
relationally they were about to hit you
they had to dock up a few more times you
know how it is you gotta and you were
like you gotta undock there's there's
infrastructure there you gotta you gotta
own bolt no that's right you gotta move
the give it a little time this is
there's the lifts and there's Hydraulics
involved these are all sloppy metaphors
but
um yeah and then I invited her over I
said something the fifth of July was
always me cleaning up this mess of puke
and and decorations and I said come over
and let's you know uh make hamburgers
and well you brought you invited her to
come back first date July 5th that's our
anniversary so you met again Yoga Yoga
hey six months later hey how did you get
in touch with her I said which I said
what's your name she told me your name I
found her online on Facebook oh Facebook
I mean we're old school it's been a
while it's been a while yeah yeah and
shuffled through the Mom memes and found
her and uh and then and her at the time
her boyfriend was in her profile picture
so I
I invited them both and then and then
that was it first date and then but they
did have a trip planned to Italy for
that fall so I was like well and then we
took our time and then eventually it
worked out wait they took that trip they
took that trip and and she was like
we're not I'm not and I was like yeah
cool whatever and then like you know we
were just kind of not dating for a while
but then we eventually
they got day we were dating and then I
got a job and I was you know it was like
I was shooting that show I got up to
shoot a show off for Netflix and then
like I was in New York for like three
months and I was just like we had just
started we had made it official then I
got the job and I was in New York and I
was like I'm so happy
that I got this awesome woman in my life
and I was like I knew I would I had like
what a new Nate dude new Nate the old
Nate would be like I just started damn
it someone else
oh damn yeah yeah yeah what a piece of
[__] new Nate well new name the old Nate
was I don't think Old Navy only it was
just a little drunk on his nuts you know
like yeah he was a Honda Accord Honda
Accord it's like when you hit the
nitrous buttons and spoilers spoiler
alert Nate like you had a spoiler yeah
it alerted people
I don't know if that worked thank you
very much yeah that worked I think that
worked so you were filming something in
New York staying long dist yep and then
and just like calling her and being like
you know [__] Gabriel Byrne today
like it was like wow yeah it was great
and like she's and she's not in the biz
she's not in the business at the time
she was an ICU nurse now she's in med
school oh yeah yeah do a lot of nurses
yeah I guess is that like a I think it's
a thing a lot of them become MPS and or
like military police nurse practitioners
wait MP doesn't stand for nurses sorry
I'm mumbled no you didn't my mind sauce
hasn't kicked in yet
you drank it backwards so it's making
you stop
put it in his butt
um if you do poor matching wind up your
butt you become dog
four to six hours of anti-flow lose it
a lot of people take it to the hospital
it sounded like he was having a stroke
turns out he put a tincture in his ass
so not this is new for me not a lot of
nurses necessarily are like they're not
doctors in training but your your
partner is yeah she just was like
um
she had
she had been in medicine for eight years
she had a career at in a ICU at UCLA and
was like I don't know what to do and I
think I'd make a pretty good doctor well
and I was like get that [__] get that
[__] sorry is that kid in the Barbie
movie I haven't seen it but I understand
he's evolved I don't know I'm just
hoping that he has yeah I think uh I
think that that was the best move for
her she she's kind of like standing at
the edge looking you know at like the
daunting task of like making it through
med school but like
well I love the bit you have a bit about
how your uh wife is better than you a
better person oh not even close how do
you feel as a comedian as a weird
I don't know I think the older I get I
think we're all getting better in our
40s but I also feel like I'm coming more
I'm getting more comfortable saying that
comedians are compulsive
weirdos wounded weirdos oh yeah yeah
intense compulsion meaning all my 20s
and 30s I was like saying like all these
therapists that are like get in touch
with the part of you that needs to make
people laugh and is trying to
crunch audiences up into a whatever
shaped hole and kind of like spackle it
inside now I'm like no that's completely
true like you don't get into this I I'm
gonna say I don't get into this if I
didn't have a compulsion meaning like
it's uncomfortable to not do it in fact
I'll take it a little bit further and
say that in my family sometimes I would
feel and they did their best they gave
me attention and love and all that stuff
but I was looking for a higher level of
identity I was looking to be recognized
in a way that I didn't feel was met
necessarily it is a strange so I needed
strangers to match that it's a it's a
combination of like intense insecurity
and also like a pretty
pretty clean confidence in yourself
confident to be able to be like look
look look look I'm not feeling like this
is all put together just in case you
agree with me I'm gonna put it together
for you yeah like and like and then once
you and then if I do it successfully
can everything be okay yeah inside of me
that's right but when we're thinking
about our time starting in Chicago
the people that I remember I'm not
putting them down I remember deeply
funny people doing stand-up and doing
well at it I'm not even talking about
any of the the big names that you know
I'm talking about people whose names I
don't even know right that I would see
that would murder that would win some
competition then they kind of hung it up
and that's fine in fact that's
appropriate the people that like stuck
with it weren't necessarily the funniest
ones they would become the funniest ones
but they were the ones that that needed
it again my Val was talking about like
when I feel like my father doesn't see
me I vanish I stop existing like that's
what my wounded child self goes like I'm
not here apparently like the the people
that made me or whatever you want to say
don't recognize me so I must just be
vapor in the wind then of course I would
get on stage and be like I'm not vapor
in the wind like I have fans come up to
me and go like Val how's Brody and I and
I mush them up and I put them in the dad
hole yeah it doesn't fully work uh
ultimately I had to go in and I'm still
doing like repairs that have nothing to
do with validation but uh those were the
people
what do you think about that I mean the
compulsive 100 of it yeah yeah I mean
I've I can be honest with you I've never
done I've never gone to therapy I did
when I was young my mom didn't like how
much I was drinking when I was in high
school so she had me go see somebody and
like I don't know that was
um I wasn't ready for that but since
then I've never gone to therapy and it's
it's uh
you know listening to people way smarter
than me talk about
um getting getting kind of like things
put in perspective for them is is always
so fascinating because it you know it's
it's those simple terms are very
valuable
um I don't think that it's rocket
science trying to figure out why we do
stand-up comedy though yeah um you know
in the context of a relationship I think
that we are
the ball and chain
um you mean you're the ball engine I'm
going to go ahead and say we are Peter
but but
I didn't mean I'm I'm opting out of what
you're saying I'm saying you mean in
your marriage yes
and all of Comedy no that's ex you're
hearing my question perfectly yeah thank
you because I'm saying between Val and I
I'm the ball in totally I'm the one
that's going like I don't know if I feel
like swimming in the lake today cause
like something interior is grinding me
wrong right she's just I I'm not she can
be as complicated and as nuanced as
anybody right and in general she's the
sunlight and I'm I'm the shadow yeah
yeah yeah and I joke about that too I
mean that it all comes off of you know
trying to say just broadly that my wife
is a better person than me but yes when
it comes to who's
good cop who's bad cop like I'm you know
she thinks she says I like to be an
[__] and it's I say that's a
technicality but she uh can I ask
something yeah she finished that thought
I won't forget um I just I just think I
just think it comes from
I can probably complicate things a
little bit more than she does can I ask
you something though yes and can I give
you a little bit of love please do
touch
um I'll put in the terms of The Vow that
sometimes I say things that aren't in a
aren't appropriate or like I go in the
direction that we shouldn't go I'm
testing limits in social situations like
looking for where's the boundaries yeah
I want to bang on the walls of the
prison and just see where the where the
weak spot is so we can start spooning so
we can start spooning you know like
Shawshank sure and um that's not always
appropriate but Pete Holmes redefining
spooning
Val and I do both kinds of spooning we
spoon at night but also I will spoon my
way out of the prison
lemon I will melon ball my way out of if
Andy Dufresne had a melon baller he
would have made it out before that storm
yeah he would have never had to he would
have never had to send the warden to
jail he'd be fine he'd be gone he'd be
gone
and did the frame uh listen what I'm
saying is Val in her she's a love genius
and she really knows how to love
everybody in her life and I am great
gratefully not an exception to that
obviously I'm her husband but she tells
me and what I'm about to tell you she's
like I like when you're kind of an
[__] and I like that you're kind of
it's flattering to call me dangerous but
I'm just saying like a little socially
like a like a Roman Candle like there's
some controlled yeah she likes it she
admires it she tells me this I'm not I'm
not speculating she says look I know I
say hey this friend is coming can you
please not this this and this but she
also wickedly Delights yeah did you hear
when I said uh
like there are moment
s of proud when someone's like we should
do that thing and I'm like yeah I'm not
gonna do
it just like right to there and it's
beautiful yeah because most people
are living in a comfortable you know
restraint it's not a prison they can
break out they can move out of it and
when you're with it and this is the
compliment this love I'm trying to give
you if you're a little bit naughty a
little bit Wicked that's what she loves
about you whether or not she's there or
no she'll tell you she does because
she's such that's exactly she's such a I
asked you back on this podcast because
I'm like I hope he just tells me what a
gentle boy he is he went to the grocery
store and he left three pennies and took
none no and that's what I love about
your special I'm like listen to this
free person a liberated person and
that's what she loves and that's what I
love thank you buddy look at that leg
keep kicking he's kicking me can we get
an inside of the legs
um no she definitely follows rules and
appreciates I think she doesn't go as
far as Val as to tell me that she
appreciates yeah that took any
irreverence or whatever but she's you
know I mean she's just
a very
um capable person like she's effective
yeah and she's been able to operate in
the system where she's following the
rules I was following the rules
I was the last one to finish my test
following the rules was like the never
never like really
uh reaped I never reaped any benefits
from the system that everybody was
playing by and like I couldn't do it
couldn't do it I couldn't even do it it
wasn't that I it was like I couldn't do
it and then I acted like I didn't want
to do it but I couldn't do it and I I
felt a lot in a lot of my life and I
still do probably and this is probably
like getting towards like you know what
you're talking about like being seen or
something a lot of times it just made me
feel dumb it makes me feel dumb like
constantly going through the system
would you please high-five this because
thank you it makes me feel dumb and and
I'm with you and in a lot of scenarios I
don't know if I'm not dumb but I don't
give a [__] because in other situations
that I'm able to produce and construct
for myself well that turn out to be very
smart and then that fixes it that's the
cure for dumb yeah it's like I haven't
said this in a while I think it was
someone like Will Rogers or something
like wasn't he a cowboy yeah and a
writer and a producer and everything
there you go he said
um I don't know what you're dumbing but
everybody's dumb in something something
I'm paraphrasing it poorly but like the
cure for dumb isn't to necessarily like
White Knuckle your way through that and
learn physics maybe it is for some
people but for me it's to find the
things you are smart at yeah you just go
like I'm not good at this and you move
on and you find what you're good at is
there anything better than that right
nothing it's the best yeah and it's but
it's sometimes you got to learn the hard
way which is working so hard towards
something you want so badly and then
realizing like
you know uh all the wrong places dude
you know what can pin up what can penob
dude you gotta like stop looking for
that nub dog you gotta like I can't
believe I'm working fine
Murphy singing doing buckwheat on
Saturday
way
we're so old that's like that 70s SNL
right there dude two AARP magazines are
delivered to us oh wow what can putting
up is on the cover wow two men get that
reference Crystal Pepsi I go you can see
right through me like Crystal Pepsi and
he went what's Crystal Pepsi and this
dude's in his 30s and I was like well
it's time for me to just walk into the
ocean not only do I know Crystal Pepsi I
know the good Crystal Pepsi huh and then
when they change the recipe and Crystal
Pepsi started to suck remember that no
for the first like month Crystal Pepsi
was awesome it was so good tell me it
was so good what did they do I don't
know they changed I can't prove anything
I felt like they changed the recipe this
is like a new Coke situation High School
Nate Craig was Furious that Crystal
Pepsi had wronged him
because I was in on crystal Pepsi I
think I walked to the downtown Center to
buy a crystal Pepsi like I saw the
commercial and I was like we'll see
about this crystals
in um The Tipping Point all they did was
not add color okay it was less by the
way Aquafina is also Pepsi it's the same
water and they just didn't add anything
and it cost the same yes now world
they're selling us bottles they're
some somebody else said that but that's
an easy one like they're just selling us
bottles it's just a bottle they're gonna
be okay shifting to wind and solar as
long as we buy bottles yeah that's crazy
the whole the whole the whole ocean is
gonna have to look like one of those
floatable rafts oh my God that's all
they care about buy bottles you [__]
slaves that's gonna be I think about you
know what I think is also out I was
watching bottles will be out bottles
will be the like scoring of our time
like can you believe okay like I'm sorry
these are plasma you still occasionally
are rocking a plastic bottle and [__]
sucks I get it
and I do it it's like my friend same
friend who didn't know what Crystal
Pepsi is he goes look every once in a
while we all throw away a battery
and I was like that is a brilliant
observation like you're caring about the
planet you're just holding a couple D
batteries just going like I I don't I
don't know what to do the rechargeable
ones don't work what do you mean the
charger breaks the batteries just stop
taking the charge on that just to get us
like good rechargeable nobody's
interested dude did you read this story
in the New York Times about about Skype
I know who our Senators are so I'm gonna
say no I didn't read the article in the
New York Times anyway we can move on but
no tell me just Skynet get guess guess
the number of satellites that Elon Musk
has in outer in orbit around the Earth I
don't know what gambling is but give me
the over under like your bet over under
I don't know the overhead I'm gonna say
he has 300 three it's like it's over ten
thousand
ten thousand like he controls
Communication in like the low orbit of
the earth like countries are like what
what do we do with this guy like Taiwan
doesn't want to have anything to do with
him because he sells too many cars to
China and they think that he's got like
it's crazy wait what is that what does
that mean because the test he's selling
too many Teslas to Chinese making Teslas
and Chinese selling Teslas in China so
Taiwan doesn't trust um him to handle
their Communications because he thinks
that China can influence him and it's
like there's like these geopolitical you
know factors that are now kind of
overlapping and intersecting with like
you know capitalism and it's it's
through him and his oh wow and SpaceX
doesn't know about SpaceX and musk's
musk's uh satellites is that um Sky
gazers uh what is star Watchers what do
you call them stats telescope Folk
oh are pissed about these satellites
dorks yes
they're pissed because if you it's
changing like a time lapse image all
you'll see are streaks satellites
because the satellites are going for
real they're yeah they're in a thing
yeah you can crazy all I know is I
always wait for Elon to just one day be
like come to me my pretties and every
Tesla just drives back to him sure
they all flock in it's real comic book
[__] man it is I don't know that was the
deleting Twitter off my phone when they
changed the just the logo that's how
that's how dumb my brain is like I was
like I'm still on Twitter fine I'm still
up I'm here I'm still gonna be on
Twitter and then finally he changed the
thing to X and I was like get the [__]
off I don't understand what that means
he changed the little bird the Twitter
bird to an X
like twitters does not call Twitter
anymore it's not it's called X
right there at the bottom in the middle
X that's Twitter now no what did you not
do it do I tweet I should you not I mean
you would if you were still on there but
I was just I just put one I was just
like this blows I'm out of here find me
and I'd put my cities and then I just
like had my pin tween I just put it off
my phone I'll probably go back on there
eventually if I have to like post
something or want to like but like wow
yeah I didn't know peace in the Middle
East bro like X X Out X-Men why do you
do it I don't care who cares and he's
something he's got he's pitching people
on you know it becoming like a banking
uh app and like all this other [__] and
like what I don't know it just kind of
got it you know Twitter was where
where like
it was a very valuable tool for a while
and then it became just kind of like a a
Time sock and energy suck for a lot of
people for some reason it was like the
most toxic of the places it was pretty
bad and it just definitely wasn't
there's more toxic places on the
internet but like for the I mean for the
user ship for the big yeah definitely
and I mean I don't know I'm it's it's
was it's a nothing but
thank you thank you for taking that away
so that nobody yeah you know all that
time yeah we can all do well it's one of
those situations where like
well there what was I reading this is
great by the way oh good I like that it
has um do you I I also take this as a
supplement hmb do you know what hmb is I
don't know what hmb helps your body with
recovery so it's really good after
workouts and before workouts good and
now that I'm older watermelon too is
really good for Recovery it can seem
very fit thank you and then I'm just
like yeah I've been looking at your body
but I'm like look at my body you also
look very fit buddy you're taking care
of it you got things you got your little
fix it gadgets your little bronze
bracelet I was having headaches behind
my left eye and I put this on and I I
don't know if it helped or if it's
psychosomatic but I don't care who gives
a [__] yeah who cares at 44 right I'll
put on a bracelet it's so much better
than them being like your brain's
expanding and you're gonna explode yeah
you should probably have this thing that
we tested on eight generations of bunny
rabbits that's right yeah no no no I'll
do this yeah I'll do this I'll just wear
this I'll do this and you know when I
put this thing on and consider pain
differently exactly I was in a coffee
shop and this Barista just goes like
gotta get those essential medals on your
body and I was like all right that's a
little sign from the universe this guy
just yelled essential medals I'm like
all right I'm on board have you ever
almost died Nate there are all these
questions I asked since you've come on
this podcast wow they're new questions I
I don't
you've never almost died you seem like
such a wakeboard almost died you seem
like such a I'm Marty mcflyde on the
back of a pickup truck and a skateboard
and I almost died
um I got rip tides
I've been pulled out by a rip before
yeah pulled out by a rip got um I don't
know if I've ever almost died I mean I I
always think about how close I come to
getting just pancakes by automobiles on
a regular basis walking walking but like
I thought about that driving in today I
was like I'm going 73 miles an hour and
so is everyone else and I don't know
these people yeah it's why it's why um
that's so that's one thing my wife has
always said you're never getting a
motorcycle because she worked in the ICU
so she saw like this is not not good
yeah listen the percentages are bad
listen to the doctors yeah yeah I listen
to the doctors listen to the doctors my
ex-wife's dad I mean we don't need any
more data on smoking but he he was like
a lung therapist and he was like just
don't smoke he's like just just he
didn't even give me details yeah he's
like just trust me he's going in and
playing the Bongos on people's lungs
trying to get him to move a pound of
butter yeah it's [__] disgusting just
don't smoke
I'm super excited you guys we have a new
Pete's pick on this episode and run do
not walk to check this one out this app
is brought To Us by our friends at brain
FM brain FM has been a part of my daily
creative routine for years now and I'm
so happy to be partnering with them
every morning I sit down at my computer
throw on my headphones these headphones
hit Focus hit creative flow and boom I'm
in the pocket ready to work create and
focus without it I find it so much
harder to complete tasks I procrastinate
I have a hard time meeting deadlines
even if they're my own self-imposed
deadlines for my own good but with brain
FM I am signaling to my brain literally
that it is time to get things done and
it works so what is it on the surface
brain FM seems like an app that gives
you the perfect background music for
Creative work study reading meditation
relaxation and sleep and that is true it
is incredible music to work or read or
meditate to but under the surface it is
doing so much more than that brain FM's
composers work hard to create create
amazing sounding music that doesn't
distract and uses their patented audio
technology to boost your mental state on
demand brain after Adams scientists and
composers they add patterns to their
music that change the patterns in your
brain creating increased blood flow and
electrical connectivity activity in the
brain and increasing focus in as little
as five minutes Regular Music think
about it is designed to be distracting
it wants your attention so you're
constantly interrupted using regular
stuff to skip you have to skip and it
pulls you out of that flow that you're
trying to get into so skip the skipping
with brain FM you can get a wide variety
of sounds and genres from natural
soundscapes to Lo-Fi electronic music
that get you in the zone almost
immediately without having to pick the
perfect playlist and it's science-backed
brain FM actually has the scientific
research to back up their claims through
close collaboration with neuroscientists
and a wide array of field experiments
and testing but even better their music
is made by real composers not computers
and and but in instead multi-interm
instrumentalist composers that way the
soundscapes on brain FM still have the
warmth of real people so check it out
support the show support your brain
support your creativity your goals and
and procrastination go to brain dot fm
weird to get 30 off thirty percent off
your first year of brain FM and start
getting more done with less effort and
unlock your best self on demand
experience the difference that the right
music can make in your life go to
brain.fm weird for 30 off we're also
brought To Us by our friends my new
favorite best looking best feeling
shorts I've ever owned bird dogs I've
never been a big short guy that is true
and it turns out I was rocking the wrong
shorts even though I love swimming I
also hate swim trunks but bird dogs
change both of those categories for me
especially now that it's summer I love
liberating my legs and getting in water
as often as possible and now thanks to
my dogs I can get and do that while
feeling totally comfortable and looking
really good bird dogs make you look good
bird dogs have stretch khaki shorts
designed for a fit Slimmer through the
thigh and leg giving you a truly
sculpted look which I love and bird dog
shorts do the exact same thing as
Lululemon but fit way better and
honestly you know yeah they look better
and it's not Lululemon they're not stiff
restricting cotton bird dogs fix this
issue by inventing Cloud knit fabric
that looks just like khaki but stretches
so you get a way Slimmer fit without
having to sacrifice movement and bird
dogs uses anti-stink anti-sweat like
sweat wicking fabric that keeps you cool
and dry all day long so go to
birddogs.com weird and you get a free
Yeti style tumbler with your order I use
this tumbler almost every day I love it
that's birddogs.com weird for a free
Yeti style tumbler you won't want to
take your bird dogs off we promise you
support your short look support your
bathing suit look and support the show
birddogs.com weird alright everybody
let's get back to Nate
um were we talking about almost dying oh
I did fall out of the back of a truck
once okay that was probably I look I
think about that and it makes me like
what happened uh well I was just up
working up north at a summer camp I was
like a maintenance guy at a summer camp
and all my all my friends grew up at the
camp and they were counselors and I was
riding in the back of the truck and like
I was standing up in the truck and we
were going slowly down like kind of like
a a you know a cut through road to like
a back athletic field and then my buddy
got to the end of the thing and I was
just kind of daydreaming and he sped up
and then he turned and I just flew out
of the truck and like I bought the next
thing I knew I was like sitting straight
up like this on the truck or sitting
straight up like this on the ground and
they like stopped and came are you okay
and it was like I
that was like
I Ragdoll it was yeah it was um I bet it
would have been pretty funny to see but
also horrifying horrifying I mean not
for you it was horrifying yeah you were
first person yeah I
pretty
yeah pretty pretty nice rotation I'm
sure the rotation was perfect just
because I landed like yeah on my butt I
was sitting up like it was perfect it
was like a you know it's like a idiot
baby falling off a mattress
you know it turned out but that's that I
think about that you know I've hit my
hat on the bottom of a pool before that
I always that I always think about oh
yeah yeah yeah ah yeah yeah yeah hate
hate it yeah that's one right here doing
it yeah yeah got the [__] I know dude I
think about that
wait he just jumped in and bunked it was
it was an old it's an old neighborhood
pool back where I grew up so it was like
the diving well wasn't that deep and it
started to the incline started only
people who have hit their heads on the
bottom of pools know the term diving
well diving well it turns out the diving
well wasn't it's a support group of
people ads and they're like oh yeah
that's a lawsuit right there in a wall
oh and put the wall on right how deep
was the one this wall is not the code
you're gonna have to move that wall back
you have to push that back right there
you're gonna have to go straight up
right there
the guy who what does that call the
contractor
never swims no never has never touched
the stuff don't get in there half of
these Wells are made for people to break
their faces half of these Wells are
gonna hurt you I just think I don't want
to get too dark because it is a dark
subject but it's just like the Majesty
of diving married with the tragedy of of
being a quadriplegic yeah it's what it's
just the worst yeah it's just the worst
so I'm so glad you're okay okay yeah
okay because that guy came in there
he's like okay okay hold up yeah yeah uh
what about ghosts you ever see a ghost
I've never seen a ghost I don't
necessarily believe in ghosts uh
necessarily a little opening if he wants
a specter to visit him tonight I ghost
if necessarily is gonna visit you I I
love I love a nice I love a nice uh
Cosmic uh Rhythm karmic uh occurrence
but just a just the predictability of a
human existence and kind of I mean goes
through too obvious ghosts are a little
bit that's a narcissism
it's kind of along the same lines as
like everybody thinks like the world's
gonna end while they're alive speed
agree what's that called I'm just
agreeing with you quickly yeah
what was that speed agree oh okay all
right I didn't go over the lingo but uh
I'm sorry I didn't know the vernac
forgive me weirdos no that's not even a
show thing that's just a me thing okay
speed used to say it in a writer's room
yeah so slow so speed agree and I think
yes but the the world is gonna
everyone's always thought the world was
going to end and when there happened to
be here and that's like just total
narcissism yeah oh really yeah yeah to
the mix uh thinking God is mad at you is
is an absolute narcissistic trip oh how
about yeah I'm gonna I'll see your I'll
see your uh speed agree and I'll raise
you a speed degree thinking Scott is mad
at someone else is maybe the most not
narcissistic and God hates everyone you
hate yeah but is that just you literally
is that just you what do you mean is
that just another that's like you've uh
just creating one stupid simple you know
monkey layer of protection for yourself
around like crushing everybody else's
Behavior up and putting it in that that
hole wait what do you mean like it's
kind of another version of like hating
other people hating other people is just
your wanting to please other people
I think I understand what you're saying
um sorry if it's a bro if it's just a
little bit of a reach it's like
you know you know like the anger is
crying yes anger is is weeping you know
like that's why I see Donald Trump Jr
screaming on the I just see a I
literally just see him weeping me too
and daddy do you see me
daddy do you care we've sang this before
I have a billion dollars I have found
golden hair
nobody acts that way nobody acts that
way to figure out what they needed
um so like you know it's I mean it seems
so
diametrically opposed you know whereas
you would kind of own your hatred of
other people as opposed to like being a
victim of your cell owned self-loathing
but in reality they're kind of you know
just a pretty simple oh yeah you can I
would differently can't handle your own
self-loathing yeah so you then projected
onto other people for sure and then go
they're the idiots I do it constantly
yeah but at least this is it's like you
can be uh ignorant or you can be
consciously ignorant I'm consciously
ignorant I'm like I know I'm doing it at
least I know I'm doing it it's a little
bit more empowering so yeah it's a ton
it's a huge step there's only one more
step yeah which is not doing it and the
step there is to know you're doing it
and I know that I I do it all the time
yeah constantly judging other people and
it's so I can go I'm a good boy and
they're a bad boy as I've gotten older
I've gotten really good at once I feel
myself you know you get whipped up in
your brain you get like a couple
thoughts in a row Chain Reaction about a
certain thing that really drives you
nuts and it changes your physicality
sure like it it shoots those those that
juice into you yes I've gotten way
better as I've gotten old and be like
stop it oh really cut your comfort zone
you know how to do that yeah it's like
the thing you're most familiar with it
empowers you it makes you feel empowered
because you can do that you can feel it
that's anger anger it's the easiest
emotion it's like it's I agree it's like
any you know
that's I think it's what we've kind of
like mistaking
people mistake anger for strength a lot
like they mistake
kindness for weakness sure and it's
that's a very low level understanding of
your own human existence yeah if you're
if if you're if that really feels right
to you you haven't ever considered just
the base kind of Simplicity of that
emotion
um so now when you feel
again having just seen my parents I've
noticed just how in my body these
feelings are we think we're thinking
like boy I'm angry but then when you get
a little bit more in your body you're
like oh it's like boiling acid in my
stomach it's a clenched jar or like your
tight fingers and all that stuff and
that is sort of the first step to just
kind of
if that's where it's starting that's
where you can start that's where the
solution is to you can start releasing
it breathing a little bit trying to get
in touch with those feelings
acknowledging them I think they just
want to be acknowledged a little bit but
you tell me you're I'll give myself I uh
I'm an advocate for road rage in general
I think that's a safe place I mean I
think it's got to get out I don't think
that you can I mean I don't think you
can possibly solve it that it's such a
monkey
where you like road rage I do
I do I just do I think it's pretty
healthy
just what as long as you're not it's
like being at the Ballpark and you can
be like [__] you it's like that yes
it's like a useful way safe way as long
as you're not like running down school
children yes but I mean I don't think
actually like endangering people's lives
in your automobile but like but you mean
like the dance of it I flip you off you
flip me off it's pretty useful yeah I
was wrong but you'll never hear it from
me you know you know what I like that's
hilarious by the way
this happened to me recently uh two
three days ago I changed lanes and I
just didn't look enough which is crazy
and they did honk and they were right
yes and then they did the thing where
they passed me fast yes it's like the
it's like that's how they get mad at you
yeah it's just show you they Zip by you
like I want to get the [__] away from
you you idiot I was thinking about this
Nate maybe you can help me there's no
hand gesture for like
I'm sorry like I was wrong I kind of did
like a like I I know but it kind of
looks like I'm going like easy yeah I
think they probably got you I think they
got you yeah I think this is universal
for um this is like a universal because
if it's if it's anything but this
there's a there's a gesture there's a
there's a yeah like that's different I'm
like a gentle hand up yeah can I tell
you about something I think about all
the time and you as a road rage
connoisseur can help me yes so I'm on
the road this is back when I was married
the first time so I must be like 23. and
uh I see this this young couple also and
and I I don't know if race is important
but as a young white couple
and they start changing lanes into a
truck that is driven by a large like
heavy not like muscly not Terry Crews
but a black guy but a big heavy black
guy and they're they're changing lanes
and he swerves it's scary he like he
really was wronged these Knuckleheads
did not look and endangered his life in
their Hyundai in their Honda and he's
got he's in a real he's got a like a
18-wheeler
it's like a it was like a pickup truck
or maybe just like an SUV okay and he's
like
and then he straightens himself
and I'm watching and then I watch as it
unfolds they pull over a lane because
they're just like we just [__] they look
like 19 years old like in my mind
because I was a young married couple
like they're probably like a young
married couple two two ding bats just a
couple married nice girls yeah just just
like me religious 19 year olds and uh
track guy he does missionaries he
doesn't do Angry speed off
he does the more frightening thing which
is he slows down and gets behind them
and then starts following them and I was
fascinated with what was happening you
follow him
okay I'm not a man I'm a 22 year old
Newlywed you follow him I did not follow
him are you following this big block no
this is a better story
this is also kind of we had cell phones
but not in the way that we have cell
phones now
it's T9 yeah it was a Nokia
my my ringtone on my Nokia was called
jump and it was
done
jump super dork great song All right so
what happens the big black guy poor
missionaries poor young white couple big
black ball narrativizing this as that's
what I heard but blessedly and as
racially as you I'm just kind of noting
it's hard they're a dynamic it's hard to
hear your own voice
there's another difference Youth and
he's definitely in his 30s like he's a
grown man and these are two little
scamps there's a lot of differences
all I did was I drove past them
terrified for everyone involved and I I
looked and the guy in the car was like
this
like like going real like right on their
butt and I was like what do you do and
you know what I might you're the kind of
guy I might call if I'm if I just really
risk the life of somebody and they're
really mad at me you're on that list
you're on the list of like call Nate
don't call me and just go Nate I want no
part of this man that you wronged well
that's that's what makes it so
interesting is you did almost kill him
you did yeah yeah he went whoa he like
fishtailed he has a right to be mad yeah
but there are no hand gestures that can
say I'm sorry stop following me I don't
want to talk about this 20 years like
you you pull over you roll down the
window you try to talk to him like let
him yell at you yeah because that'd be
helpful to your Point Road Rage it's
healthy it's not going anywhere let him
call me a piece of [__] I don't like the
fall away I don't like
that looks like it's gonna you know it's
more menacing it's menacing it's it's
yeah it's like this could be your
behavior on the road does not just have
to happen here on the road like this we
could take this we can take this off the
road we can take this inside yeah you
want to take this you want to step
inside yeah exactly so what would you
what do you do uh I've given a lot of
thought so I have an answer I think he
just kind of I mean if somebody wants to
do that you know they got a really
really
they gotta really really feel strongly
about an accident that didn't happen yep
good job you saved yourself I almost
caused problems for us and you know you
got to do what you got to do what do you
mean you're saying you pull over and
fight no no but if he's gonna follow me
and wants to fight me when we get to
when we get to where I'm going because
I'm in this house I'm I'm going to
Nana's you're gonna kick my ass in
Nana's driver you're gonna have to kick
my ass in front of my own grandmother my
only if that's what you want to do drive
until he calms down keep going you're
throwing that cartole CDs Adam
thrawn's self-help book religious
pamphlets yeah and yeah you're blasting
and yeah
you're driving those down drive up to
church you weren't going to church yeah
go to church go to church and drive into
the sanctuary you can't because a lot of
fights happen in the church parking lot
you got to go into the sanctuary so
you're up the stairs in the in the
fellowship hall and then you get out
School for the Blind and go they can't
they won't who who's right and who's
wrong go to a playground playground you
can't let these kids see what's about to
happen yeah yeah sir please for the
children can we let this go for the
children
turn it up really loud you get out of
your car you're like you know what I
know that I know what happened back
there I just want to listen to me for
just one second I know what happened
back there the return to innocence
sir are you married
have you ever had a disagreement have
you ever had a disagreement behind the
wheel of a car well I think that's what
they say you should go like my name is
Michael Daniels I'm Michael I live my
South Bend Indiana I like Indian food
but I can't handle spies like this is
what you have to yell at this man
humanize yourself
can't watch
what's that what's that Silence of the
Lambs he's humanizing her oh they're
trying to humanize her is that a thing
yes I I feel like it was silence and
lands when they when they get on when
they're the parents are talking about
the name of the the
one their chick that whole traps his dog
oh no your dog's in a lot of pain sir
Mister that chick her parents are on TV
I've only seen it they're like using her
name when I saw Silence of the Lambs I
was so scared I was mad that I was
watching it oh when she's in the dark
that's good yeah I love your line that's
a good good it's a good movie that's a
yeah I'll never watch it again hold on
hit it what did you like I liked when
you said that Putin is the bartender in
The Shining oh yeah yeah Putin's balls
are the bartenders balls are the
bartender in the chatting just stirring
up trouble our joints eject our our
bodies are turned to Mush and our balls
are serving drinks the whole time
I also want a little love for finding
the return to innocence in my brain you
got that
that white folks couldn't get enough of
like kind of like a new AG song but with
like
oh yeah remember like chant could just
be like chant monks like yo
I'm taking the diner having coffee and
it's great
but instead I stir my coffee and instead
I stare in the mouth wow
wow all right he is begging for my money
and I don't have none to give him so I
go and buy more coffee and I like my
[__] coffee she's gonna drink my
coffee quickly because Here Comes one
more beggar and I don't want to make
icons instead I stir my milk Phil
Collins loved it little Kermit at the
end there milk milk instead I stir my
milk dude
Miss Piggy that's my jam
um
Phil Collins Phil Collins Another Day in
Paradise remember that song
how does he go he calls her to the man
on the streets
it was back in the 90s we didn't know
how to feel about all the homelessness
we still don't but Phil Collins was like
here I'll help oh
think twice
it's just another day for you and me in
Paradise
think twice and I don't know the next
one yeah I think he just says it again
yeah yeah white people went
real r b adjacent there that's what it
was yeah
s and C
those are the letters next to RnB
you that's not that's neurotism right
there I think we just brushed against
Autism you know how I think I how I show
up as autistic a little a little
autistic autistic and as a married man I
wonder if you can relate sometimes my
wife touches me anybody touches me and
I'm just like I can't right now on the
face anywhere anywhere on your body but
definitely on my face that's why you
keep kicking me with the bottom of your
shoe well yeah I want you to have a
degree plague that I've walked through
do you ever get that
um
that's what made me think maybe you did
yeah yeah you know this is this happened
to me yesterday I got off I was on the
plane and I uh that's where I am a rule
follower when it comes down to like I
don't have another Choice my only choice
is for the law to be obeyed I agree turn
your [__] these people texting Bolden
when you can just get on the Wi-Fi they
give you free texting Wi-Fi now still
people got that LTE up there just kind
of [__] with the instruments [__]
with the instruments what are you gonna
send this is the one I think this is the
end because I was on a window seat
couple wouldn't get up people are
streaming by us
they're getting off the plane out of
order wait you're at the window seat I'm
at the window seat my row it's my rose
turn to exit to exit the plane Nate
people are I'm not a jerk I will never
let unless there's a connection
you're supposed to let the connections
go the connections okay the connections
I understand but I I see those people
they're Veer they're they're trying to
win by a nose you know what I mean
they're coming in this is not going to
step into the aisle and and block this
is not going to make a difference for
you yeah what needs to be upheld is the
Integrity of these assistant rules of
the airplane that's right
I bet it's a written rule it's not the
end of a movie where you can all some
are going to watch the credits some are
gonna stay for the little Marvel
they're just Intoxicated by that open
aisle off the plane and I get that that
I get you have to you have to say no to
that you mean they're trying to have
like a Catholic kind of reason they see
it they see they're right there these
people are here these people are here I
could get right there maybe there's a
deep spiritual practice there's a lot of
opportunities
to like become enlightened no become
enlightened at the airplane in an
airplane at the airport just accept let
people go in front of you your place I
still can't do it I'm like I gotta get
on all right well I'm but I'm still I'm
see I'm putting what you're saying in
the context of following the [__]
rules like yeah just let's don't worry
about you wait your turn your way well
this is what I always say when Val came
with me to Manhattan I was like I always
the I always remember telling her the
way to be polite here is to be rude and
it's the same on an airplane be rude get
out go go don't be there whittling going
like we're all getting off eventually no
you're [__] up the system move up
yeah move up same with traffic yeah
that's right same with traffic you're
trying to be helpful Progressive got to
be aggressive
ER Senator is named Diane Goggins Diane
Feinstein and David Goggins no not David
Gaga Ultra marathoner David Gaga oh no
no no that's our Senator right no no no
he ran with a broken leg
ah
that's not what happened Peter by the
way with my parents as I say the most
basic thing about David Goggins all this
work that we put into our making movies
or TV or whatever it is just know to
most of the country you're just whatever
the number one headline is uh you know
what I mean like just whatever the most
basic thing about you is I like David
goggin broken leg
um Bill Burr didn't he yell at people in
Philadelphia
um just anybody anybody Star Wars well
you know with uh Pee-wee Herman dying I
know my parents jerk off in a theater
you know like that's who that's what it
is yes definitely rest in peace damn
what a what an influence in a beautiful
person but he made that mistake that's
that's the Headless State there's a lot
of people that are just you know and
that's okay that's what entertainment is
to them it's just it's just something
they sip on their way
following a young couple that just cut
them off mm-hmm
can you tell me Nate any new thoughts on
tell me oh your thoughts on God do you
have any new spiritual feelings you're a
married man now
um it's been nine years since you're on
the show I this is well this is my
Mantra in yoga Mantra Mantra yeah my
this is my favorite Mothra this is my
favorite monster yeah
um he's Dusty I um
strength symmetry Clarity and
forgiveness and that has kind of come
that is kind of calm
I'm sorry I made a screening of the new
300 movie that's that's what I wanted
for myself strength symmetry clear
because I am doing something physical it
is a physical meditation in yoga yes not
that I do a lot of it but like
um I try to do I think it's really
benefited me as a person yeah and you
know yeah uh the human body
um
and what that has become is I will they
will they'll say sometimes they'll say
think about someone you know focus on
someone and and uh send them good
thoughts and I always have chosen
somebody that I love I care very much
about right
um and friends and family and all that
but what I've been doing in more recent
years is forcing myself to think about
someone that really causes me anxiety or
stress yeah and just treating them
exactly like the people that I love
because in reality it is that yeah um
you know and that's you know
pretty humbling yeah yeah no that's it
yeah loving kindness It's Bush League to
love people that are kind and generous
to you that do something for you yeah
it's self-service it's also it's yeah
it's self-serving is better than
narcissist yeah it's self-serving it's
like oh good for you you love your kids
right when they're young and little and
you're supposed to yeah you're supposed
to love your kids exactly hilarious
but like loving the difficult people in
your life well that's Rock that's
speaking of Louisiana that's the end of
the bit I think is you know he's like
he's like ah that might be different
specials but that's a I think that's a
CK joke in Bigger and Blacker when he's
like you're I don't you know in Rock
bigger and Blacker Yeah by Chris Rock
but I think CK wrote A lot of that he
did I think he wrote some of it or yeah
really yeah I think he's got I think
it's written by Chris Rock and Louis CK
I'm not I'd have to go back and check by
this one but like there's one line that
I'm like oh that was for sure CK where
where rock is like you know women be
like I could Raise A Man with the I
could raise a kid without my man I Don't
Need No Man to raise a kid or she's like
yeah well
you're
[__] up the joke he goes uh you can
drive a you can drive a car with your
feet it doesn't mean it's to be done
with your hands
no you can drive a car with your feet it
doesn't mean it's to be done
you can drive a car with your phone oh
I'm like you do drive a car with your
feet the pedals no it doesn't mean it's
to be done yeah it's pretty clean right
it's you could yeah yeah it's it's a
pretty it's a I would it's a very
specific yeah yeah the execution of the
joke yeah no I hear you and it's like
um anyway sorry I interrupted you you
didn't did you yeah I did I totally
interrupted you and went on my own story
but I liked it I did well we're just
talking about
Purity Excellence
fortitude strength symmetry Clarity and
forgiveness so take me through all those
um just
um well strength because it feels good
it makes you feel strong
and capable and it placates my human
existence yeah uh symmetry because I
think that's something that I forget
about
um what does that mean like balance
balance yeah balance and and it's it it
doesn't it it's not just like doing
everything I can do with my right arm
with my left arm it's all at that also
kind of projects on to kind of the
balance that you need in your life you
know
thinking about people that have wronged
you just as much as you think about
people that have helped you in a good
light and you're trying to kind of you
know it's beautiful and then um Clarity
is oh that's how we got into that bed
Clarity is uh like
obvious you know just not being
distracted being Lucid not being
interrupted by your own distractions
when trying to explain what you mean by
Clarity yeah there you go and then but
single point Focus like focused is
another way to put it I suppose yeah
right you're right yeah yeah focusing on
what you're doing it doesn't mean are
you still clarity about what you're
doing I still drink yeah totally yeah I
do and then and uh totally I've been I
I'm just curious because Clarity does
sound like a sober word to me right yeah
I guess I didn't think about that I was
just no no this isn't judgment or saying
you can't use the word oh buddy I know I
was curious if there was a secret it's a
fascinating conversation is it yeah
alcohol for me tell me I mean there's a
large part of me that thinks I should
quit there's a large part of me that
says I'm doing I will not be on this
Earth long enough to have the audacity
to stop drinking wine period wine is
great it's [__] even you just saying
wine wine as if it's special it's it is
special it's [__] biblical it's great
they pair it with all our favorites I
even loves that wine loves it you know
how excited big wine was when Jesus was
like let's have some wine they were like
[__] [__] yeah they were so thrilled
he's making our [__] yeah it's coming
out of him his first miracle was making
their product yeah they were set that
doesn't mean it's not just [__] booze
it's booze it's delicious booze it's
it's understand
um
it's delicious booze and
I mean if I ever if I ever stop drinking
wine I'm gonna stop eating red meat as
well I see because I don't eat red meat
without red wine I think it's
disrespectful to the animal
I'm serious I think it's disrespectful
to the animal no I think it's I'm
serious no I'm serious no yeah I see I
got a get a drink eat the [__] cow
without the grapes that's grapes no I'm
serious why you can't possibly be
serious I am serious I'm dead serious
about that I I think that if why do I
want a steak if I don't have a glass of
wine with it I have no need for a steak
if I'm not drinking a big beautiful
glass of beautiful red wine with it
beautiful red wine beautiful red where
we love the wine we have the wine the
wine I really need more than that that's
just it's just how you feel it
complements it's the flavors the flavors
yes absolutely I just I just don't buy
it like the people that love wine and
the flavors of like we could get those
flavors with a blend of grape juices
well let me put it this way it's getting
drunk let me put it this way let me put
it this way I think that there is by my
assessment the downside of raising and
eating red meat
with nine billion people on the planet
it's not sustainable it's not so in
order to do it at the level that I think
is the most best enjoyment of it it's
got to be with a glass of wine otherwise
I don't feel like it's I don't feel like
it's it's I see what you're saying I'm
getting the most I don't I'm not I gotta
squeeze the juice you're making it
special you're saying I don't want to
smoke a cigar in a cab right you're
gonna smoke it on the balcony
of a log cabin in Aspen yeah with a
glass of scotch and alcohol shows up
again yeah
I think that's I mean it really does
heighten my enjoyment of certain things
there's a reason why it's paired with
certain things I understand and also
side note
um I don't often unless I'm like
I don't really drink whiskey anymore
just to drink
um I'm too old for that [__] I've
shifted to Tequila
um but if I am gonna drink bourbon I
like chocolate
and bourbon together yeah
these are interesting yeah it's very
it's very intense pleasure
to do that earlier very intense it's
very intense pleasure pleasure
something about that was so honest
that's what made me laugh I I just look
on your face pleasure pleasure I could
stop I could give up beer I could give
up booze
it's gonna be a hard it's gonna be a a
long long day when I stop drinking wine
I just think it's the best thing that
humans have ever done wine
interesting
spoken from somebody who doesn't have
heartburn apparently we're uh we're a
lowly We're Alone we're a lowly Hill
species and why we found out I mean
there's it's just so complex it's so
complex it makes us feel better for a
fleeting moment yeah in a way that's
like and then worse maybe if you overdo
it yes but there's a sweet spot just
like caffeine sure which you've also
been able to give up Peter good job no I
drink heavy you drink caffeine they do
okay what do you drink you drink yeah by
the way pal I completely understand what
you're saying listen here chief chief
give it to me that was a sincere pal
there's pal that's like you know it was
a sincere pal leading into you having
figured out something else about the
world definitely not I was trying to say
that's not the attitude that I'm coming
at you okay all right okay I don't feel
that it is I'll say I appreciate the
retraction I just I guess what I'm
saying is I used to get so into the the
rejection the flavors and the regions
and all that stuff and with coffee no no
with wine yeah I'd buy books about it
would buy a case of wine and do tastings
and I was like I'm an alcoholic you know
what I mean I'm just like that's just a
it's just a fancy way of of doing the
same drug is what I'm saying sure that's
that's I guess that is the Judgment if
you want to get at it oh yeah no I I
this is never this has not not been an
attack for the last 45 seconds
I but hold on now let me but that sucks
I don't want to attack no you're not but
let me ask you this you know what it is
and bristling again
not the way it is for you no no I and I
get it and I'm I'm not I wouldn't dare
to say that there aren't the exact same
components in my own relationship with
alcohol and why more specifically such
an addictive substance it really is and
I but here's let me push back just a
little bit
is there room for that
buddy let me okay I'll tell you
something I occasionally chew Nicorette
which is an addictive substance I do it
when I write wow yeah it's a stimulant
for you you've never smoked never you've
never smoked yeah I've never smoked
Nicorette and I'll chew when did you get
turned who what crack dealer gave you
your first piece of Nicorette I put it
together I was like when I smoke a cigar
I feel fantastic why I go with oh
nicotine I'm gonna Google what nicotine
does it's a mood elevator it's a new a
Trope it helps you focus why do so many
people write while they smoke I was like
well I don't want any of the death I'll
just chew Nicorette so I did smart and
here's uh well there's actually look I
can't vouch for these people you gotta
stash a Nicorette in your house of
course in my drawer your drug drawer and
it's in a time lock safe actually
I am well I'm trying to join you I'm
saying
in the height of really enjoying a piece
of Nicorette while I'm writing and it
makes my my fingers snap on the keys I'm
writing too much I love it literally I
have to go back in a non-nicorette state
take it down yeah yeah you're like wow
but that's great I'm like look I'm
making all this marble I know for a fact
I really love Nicorette Val was like
Pete you wrote your whole book on
nicotine she's like that's a nicotine
book and I was like yeah that's how you
people ask you how do you write a book
I'm like nicotine helps I'm not saying
that's the only thing that helps you can
also go for a walk beforehand but it's a
lot easier to just throw in a piece of
nigarette uh and when I'm in the throes
of really enjoying these things that I'm
addicted to coffee and nicotine I
wouldn't say I'm addicted to nicotine
though because I don't write every day
and I only chew it on days that I write
and that breaks down to about two days a
week you know who loves this whole
speech tell me big nicotine that's right
if Jesus Nick the second Nick is up
there just like hey Nick oh let's send
Pete a uh fruit basket I'm infused with
nicotine so I've gone back and forth
I'll preach the other side of it too my
thing with nicotine is keep it under
four milligrams a day which is barely
one cigarette so you're having barely
any and if I and I only do it when I
write I have to be in my chair final
draft open looking at a script that I'm
resisting writing and then I'll chew it
and if I'm at a party and I want a piece
if I'm in a plane and I'm grumpy and I
want a piece you don't get any because
as soon as you take that little piece
out of the out of the wall the whole
thing comes crumbling down and I go back
to chewing 35 pieces a day and being a
complete addict but when I was addicted
and this goes back to what I've been
trying to say to you I go what's the
difference between being addicted to
something and something just being
incredible yeah you know what I mean
that's how I feel about coffee you said
you go back to 35 pieces a day did you
ever get to a point where oh yeah oh
yeah you were crushing Nick it's
crushing it okay I shot the entire How
We Roll pilot with a piece of nicotine
in Nicorette in my mouth okay got like I
was I did and then when we got picked up
I quit because I was like [__] this so
I've done that a couple times and now
I'm on the four milligrams or less a day
and I go days without it without any but
that's I I looked up someone else to do
this this doctor I forget his name I
found him through Andrew huberman's
podcast but it was a guess and he was
talking about how he does between four
and eight only when he's writing yeah
and I was like okay I'll do that but but
the point Believe It or Not of all that
was to say that when you love it's
easier with coffee because nicotine's
weird but coffee when I you know what my
last thought of the day is most days
pretty excited for tomorrow's coffee
yeah and that is one of the great gifts
of life so I'm trying to join yeah yeah
in Brotherhood I appreciate it saying
yeah alcohol is addictive so is fat so
is sugar yeah so is sex so there's a lot
of things pleasure things yeah obviously
not everybody's addicted to those things
but they can be addictive so when you go
I can't wait to eat that steak and have
that glass of red wine if you can not
have the bottle and then another bottle
which is what I would do uh yeah I can
say good love you yeah for what it's
worth I don't need my stamp of approval
I also draw the line at 35 pieces of
nicotine gum when it comes to when it
comes to alcohol I'm I'm I have a I've
been
pretty fortunate I feel like I have a
pretty healthy
uh I wouldn't say healthy I feel like I
know where the line is and that's that's
healthy for you and I love
I love having pops with people like it's
it's so social for me like if I see
somebody and they want to have a drink I
might let's have a [__] drink I
missed you I haven't seen you in [__]
yeah months or years like let's one of
my favorite things I haven't gone
through the program but they have that
like it works till it doesn't thing
until it doesn't yeah and I like that
yeah because I because it's a denial to
say that it doesn't sort of work you
know what I mean have if you and I went
out and had a drink we might go a little
bit deeper yeah but then old homsy he's
gonna go home he's gonna keep drinking
like it's it's an issue see I see and
this is something I re recently as as
you know I wish somebody would have told
me about your [__] club so just
switched after you're done drinking
booze you get home after party just go
to Lacroix start drinking Lacroix yeah
you're getting the same thing the same
it's all about this is It's the booze
you don't need yeah you don't need that
boost so I could have done that back in
my 20s yeah yeah you don't need the
extra boots you're just like we got to
go we got to keep or nerd ends it's all
over it's just like shut up you [__]
man yeah completely God damn I
completely yeah
to do though especially if you're
addicted to alcohol addicted right okay
so then that's why I feel like um
relatively in a good place a place that
I where I don't have to kind of like you
know confront this with unnecessary
self-scrutiny because then that's just
an exercise in like controlling but you
love the weed smoke there's a lot of
references to weed smoke in your special
I'd and there was I smoke weed I smoke
it uh probably less than I drink but
okay
um like I'll smoke it I like to smoke it
when I golf
yeah I like to smoke it if I'm on like
whatever it's it's more sparing
I've just been trying to think of weed
and golf buns but yeah
four twenty yeah okay
alcohol is terrible I'm gonna if I I'm
gonna hit myself hold on I have to hit
myself in the dick we'll edit it out no
no I have to hit myself well then the
only way I learned
what I did hit my dick not my balls it
didn't hurt I got a big old coiled up
anacondas that was totally fine good
Lord jk just no you're not JK do I have
BD it's it won't you can't I can see
your phone this isn't dead it's weeping
it's just that's just pants no I'm not
looking up there I'm looking down
I know where to find it the middle third
I know where an anaconda hides middle
third uh middle third when you said
middle third I was like that's kind of a
big big joke oh I would because if you
can spare a third the middle third the
middle third of my deck a workable Ding
Dong Well it's just a I mean it's just
another way to say chop my dick off yeah
no I know
live at the Green Mill available now on
all things comedy I my wife would kill
me if I quit drinking
that's interesting yep just because we
that's our favorite thing to do is just
make a beautiful meal have a bottle of
wine we don't even need to drink the
whole thing but if it's nice food
celebrate it with a glass of wine I
really really it means
that means a lot to us we just enjoy it
and that's awesome she married a good
time
she married a good time it's interesting
if I were a therapist I'd say two things
one I find that very significant what
you just said yeah
isn't Nate a good time Nate is a good
time and it is a good time it's a joke
that's why it's a joke but but it's it
is it is it is
it is pretty presumptuous I guess yes I
wonder if that's true I want you to ask
your wife if that's true say would you
leave me if I quit drinking oh we've
talked about it we talk about a ton
who'd you marry Captain Morgan
No Maybe
you'll be sipping me wrong
you walk the plank you find a boot that
runs on sobriety
wait you've talked with your wife and
you were like you'd leave me if I
stopped drinking no no no no no no that
was not her line that's mine that's my
quip no she is probably gonna have to
stop drinking for med school like we've
definitely talked about like definitely
taking long breaks and if not quitting
and it's just like well we really do
enjoy wine with the food
it's like I don't know if I if yeah you
know if you were talking to Mario Batali
you'd be having such a better time
look here I just had like a classy
earring and I look like a street fighter
boss and I'm just like I know you gotta
have the wine so much better what good
is my wife's pirate ship if we can't
blow holes
I am being more of a bummer and if I I
don't like feeling this uptight and I
don't feel uptight but I feel like I'm
sounding up no no no I mean without
question the it takes a tremendous
amount of work
to be to quit drinking I just from the
people that I know that have done it
it's incredible it's remarkable it's
it's admirable and it is clearly a
benefit to their careers
across the board I mean like so there's
always that yeah
um I want to say something I love you
and I love you I don't want you to
change I think you're doing great this
isn't this this has the flavor of like
uh I can't wait to ask Nate about his
drinking I love you I love who you are
thank you buddy I love you too and I
don't want any any you walking out being
like I feel like Pete wants me to change
x y
that's not what I'm getting that's not
what's happening I know you're not I
know that you have a cult and you're I
can I can I can join it if I want I know
the members of my called all sneak out
and have a few pops they have some fun
they come back
don't talk don't homsy
come see me in Austin and Ann Arbor at
Chicago
and where are you playing in Chicago uh
the Lincoln Lodge I'm doing a Lincoln
Lodge Labor Day weekend the first and
second yeah have you been to the new
Lodge there's a new lot they redid the
lodge it's a [__] fantastic it is
what it always was growing to be yeah
dude
they got it it's they got three theater
three little spaces one of the main
rooms a full-on functioning awesome room
Club perfect ceilings perfect stage
perfect sound perfect aesthetic and then
they have like uh uh 250 seaters and
it's dope really yeah and they got
people they're like tons of I mean you
know how comedy is now it's not like
when we started it we were like the only
dorks in town Carney's juggling cabbages
and then now it's like it's like it's a
cool kid thing now oh it's like a
prudent investment fathers across the
country are like why couldn't you go
don't you care about your future put
together a new hour you're never gonna
make it if you don't make sense of it
all sure devil and improv but focus on
the meat and potatoes you can tour
CAA has a department for you
there's no department and yes I am
the numbers are not in your favor
sketch who are you gonna get to read
your sketch pilot you can't split 75
dollars 12 ways
you take that 75 and you bank it
Enterprise gets 50 and the rest is for
you you do stand up you keep all the
cash and all the drink tickets and you
get to do it here's my thing about
improv v stand up is I never met an
improv team that wanted to perform as
much as I did you know what I mean I was
like we're just making it up we should
do shows every night but it was too much
production getting the word out yeah
getting a space [__] sucks yeah if
you want to do it all the time you can
do it yourself yeah you don't have to
ask anybody and you can be as tenacious
as you are instead of improv teams are
only as committed as the least committed
person right which is always just the
guy who's there for the beer yeah
unfortunately the funniest guy in the
group almost always always it doesn't
have that compulsion
no work ethic
uh Kim Kardashian never emptied a vacuum
bag a lot of memorable lines thank you
buddy yeah let me ask you this let me
ask you this
and then we'll we'll wrap it we'll wrap
it
can you tell me a time in your life that
you laughed so hard you were crying
laughing your belly hurt it fell over oh
my God just like maybe the hardest laugh
of your life but it doesn't have to be
the hardest laugh you're like I have one
talk about my fourth of July party there
was one with there was a whole night
with Kyle that was
yes that was he showed up late he had
hurt his leg or something I heard my leg
he or it was like his first bout with
gout or something like that he did for a
while you know it was like Kyle it's
with some Kyle [__] Uncle barbecue dude
it's like he's so he has couch I love
that guy dude he just bought a house in
Portland it's great if Kyle's crushing
it he moved to Portland he did he moved
to Portland on the pandemic and then
like I think he just lives importantly
he lives in Portland now well just
ripping it up there the scene's great so
he just you know it's all it's all he
needs he did he did his six specials you
know like wow and he'll probably do more
he'll keep doing them yeah but like he
came over late like after the party and
and I fed him a bunch of mushrooms and
we just like shroomed out for the whole
night and like he had his friends meet
us there and they had been I think they
came from different places so his
friends his uh buddies from Chicago
where uh one of them was like
completely tossed and then the other one
ate mushrooms with us and he disappeared
into the neighborhood so it was just
this neighborhood it was just this I
mean well you know you've been to my
house it was it's kind of a fun
neighborhood especially on the fourth
yeah it's disappearable yeah yeah you
know what I mean it's like it's like
especially if you're on you didn't lose
him in like a stranger's thing so no no
he he went on a mission you know and uh
and and so we just wind up like we were
just sitting kind of way I don't know if
we had hung out in a while whatever and
we were sitting in uh on like uh
I want I don't want to name the guy's
name but our buddy of ours was had
passed out on my couch and like we were
out we were drinking there was a couple
of us around my table in my yard there
and gets up and he comes out
sleepwalking and um and takes his like
takes his dick out towards us and we're
like how's where's this gonna and he
just
heavy peas into my succulent plant like
a long piss like an indoor uh an outdoor
he was he was on my at my doorway ah got
off my couch walked to the outside at
least thank God and then
pissed into my succulent sleep test long
heavy sleep piss yeah ropey ropey you
know heavy nobody's watching pistick
late night yeah you know I'm alone my
dick after dark yes the way it hurts
just uh just a heavy hermit pee you know
piss like nobody's watching is what is
all we want for anybody that's right and
I mean he pissed like nobody was
watching and we were not only we were
watching we were all falling out of our
chair I mean we were just like we could
not it was it was in the middle of a
conversation and he it was like we were
just we like tried to like talk to him
because eyes open eyes open sleepwalking
and like not no eye contact with us we
were like and just direct piss and enemy
it took you know how a nice long piss
can take oh sure of 60. passed out
you're passed out drinking all day yeah
I mean that's a 60 second and we just
and so so this so the laughter didn't
start to stop until the piss ended
the laughter didn't start to stop until
the picture and that's a long [__]
laugh that's a great opening line to
your book yeah the laughter didn't stop
until the piss stopped until the piss
ended the laughter didn't start to stop
until the piss ended yeah and then
another laugh that we had that night
which was which at this point we had
almost we almost threw up with the piss
laugh the another laugh his so is his
drunk drunk friend was like puke drunk
trying to gather himself like sitting in
a and he like went off and sat back in
the back by my back alley past the gate
there if you remember that and like and
my neighbor Gerald plays the trumpet all
the time and he's like kind of
self-taught trumpet player and like we
like we like were out looking for his
friend and we came back and
and we turn the corner to come into my
Courtyard and his buddy Dom was like
sitting there just like kind of leaning
like but like you know trying not to
vomit and like black out drunk and like
and
my neighbor is trying to is a sweet man
he's a Buddhist he like is like very
much offering things to you a
self-taught Buddhist self-taught
Buddhist Trump trump Trump trump player
and like he's like Katie do you ever
made him Bureau my neighbor the black
Gerald
yeah he's he was always there he was
always like he just always like he was
grilled chicken and [__] for people he
would like always give people things and
like he would if you would wanted to
chant with him people would go into his
house and like and like Nami orangekyo
like with them and like and like and
he's the sweetest guy but he was playing
the horn for Dom and he he literally was
playing a trumpet in saddam's face it
was like the last thing you would want
if you were trying to if you were trying
to not puke you know and it was just
like
and that's what we me and Kyle trumpet
be cooling no it wasn't
wanted to do something for this sick
young man that was like at his house and
trying to
play me this guy just blaring it
dropping into his friend's face and we
just again same night
fantastic
it's reminding me of your closer I won't
do it but people have to listen to Live
at the Green Mill live with the Green
Mill it's a great closer thank you buddy
the story oh yeah yeah true true story
true story cop asked for a joke joke let
me hear I want to hear a joke first
real prick
he meant it too
and I was like all right well then I
mean this joke then and then and then
and he liked it and it worked I liked it
and I bounced I probably yeah yeah I get
it I was I was I mean
I was had I had I was glad I had one I
you know people ask you for a joke I
don't remember Street jokes so I'm like
yeah that's not how this works I got
it's funny that I was clearly advocating
stopping drinking but I was a little
stoned the other night and I uh told Val
every street joke that I could remember
and we were laughing hard
there's a hole in the ground these two
Hunters come upon it it's a hole in the
ground
and they're like that's the deepest hole
I've ever seen how deep do you think
that hole is and I don't know Throw That
Rock in we'll see how long it takes to
hit the bottom they throw this rock in
the hole
takes forever and then finally
the deepest hole I've ever seen took
like 30 seconds
and out of nowhere faster than lightning
a goat comes charging between them
knocks them apart goes head first
directly into the hole falls down like
what the [__]
a couple minutes past the farmer walks
up he goes have you guys seen a goat
they're like
um I don't I don't know what do you mean
you say it's got to be around here
somewhere I tied him to that rock
it's stupid I shouldn't have said that
rock a rock yeah
implied The Rock was still there can't
miss him he's trying to do a big rock
hey can't miss him I tied him to a big
rock yeah there you go there it is
the end
how do you feel I feel fantastic buddy
it's really great to see you it's great
to see you you should be really really
proud of your special thank you dude
that means a lot I love it because
we've known each other for a long long
time and uh it's been awesome to watch
you uh this whole time so
um even talking about comedy is just a
real blast and a pass and a real [__]
gift to be honest with you yeah I love
it it does make it
it does make it there's so many things
about this business that are like I said
distractions and like you know tedious
and all that but like sitting down with
with uh
people you're fans of and people who you
know work so hard to be so [__]
hilarious is like it's such a it's nice
to just be able to have any kind of
understanding about uh it is
at all
yeah I get it it's very difficult and
it's like it's like
at this point in my career I'm like I'm
so grateful to like get the [__]
be at peace with like what it is about
comedy that I like that is not just me
fixing myself yeah yeah that's like so
it's a beautiful part of it because it's
there's two there's two there is a
beautiful part yeah a very beautiful
part of it it's like hey man I [__]
had these thoughts that I want you to I
would love for you to see these and that
you worked on to make other people
delighted it's very special yeah and
that's why I appreciated the work and
the craft of it and and
he just did a really great job you
should be really proud of it I am well
the Green Mill helped that place is I
mean it looks right it does look great
and standing behind the bar I'm standing
behind the bar yeah yeah it was the
obvious choice and it also opens it up
it's like yeah as opposed to just 180.
are there really bullet holes in the
walls yeah from Capone yeah wow yeah
they came for they came for that dude at
that place it came from everywhere but
like there's that there's a tunnel onto
that stage to get him out of there wow
yeah yeah great they're guys that shot
at uh Hunter Connor's term uh and Jack
Whaley are the uh the Director of
Photography and then my guy whose crew
came down to shoot it and um they made
it look [__] gorgeous I was like
we're doing the green and I was like
have you ever been there and I don't
know if he had or not but they scouted
it and they were like this is going to
be great yeah and it's like it's such a
dope spot I didn't want the Green Mill
sign to be like to dominate also I
thought the bar was the best choice just
for the sight lines yeah but like also
that it's way better in the background I
think it really oh yeah it really lends
itself
I'm going to be honest with you my penis
has hurt since I hit it you hit your
dick yeah well I thought it was Stevo do
you even remember the shitty joke you
made yeah 4 20. okay well good let your
dick hurt
you dumbass
you [__] corn bag get those essential
medals on you you [__] corn bag this
discussion about comedy and life has
been brought to you by Magic mine oh you
look you put the wrong cap on it look a
little a little black top it's because I
put it up my butt that's lost track of
all
cognitive function
would you say keep it crispy Nate this
is so fun I love talking with you can I
can I promote my dates sure is that
possible go ahead [__] [__] [__] [__]
Austin Texas August 18th 19th Chicago
Illinois September 1st and 2nd San
Francisco at the punch line September
20th uh Ann Arbor comedy showcase
September 29th and 30th
hilarities in Cleveland November
16th through the 18th you were how
awesome is that club it's great I'll be
with Bill on tour in October dad
now I'm serious that
that I'll be uh at the Majestic Theater
in Madison Wisconsin December 27th and
then I'll be at the Laughing tap for New
Year's Eve weekend in Milwaukee
Wisconsin and I might have another
I got a few more coming so yeah it
doesn't sound time to quit drinking with
those days Nate craig.com it's never
gonna happen alcohol Vegas is on the
schedule a couple times yeah
that's Milwaukee that's why I call
Milwaukee oh alcohol Vegas oh ladies and
gentlemen
from Pete and myself and KT please keep
it crispy
I love that you did that so
professionally